WHY ARE THE MEDIA DITCHING THE
FACT-CHECKERS IN THE BIDEN AREA?
RAYMOND ARROYO HAS AT ALL AND
SEEN AND UNSEEN.
FIRST, THE REAL EXTREMISTS.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
TODAY, JOE BIDEN MADE IT
OFFICIAL, MR. UNITY WILL HEAL
THE WOUNDS OF THE DIVIDED
AMERICA BY USING THE POWER OF
THE ENTIRE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
HARASS AND INVESTIGATE HIS
POLITICAL ADVERSARIES.
FROM OUR BLOATED INTEL AGENCIES
TO THE DOJ AND FBI, HE AND
KAMALA HARRIS WILL SPY ON
AMERICANS THEY DON’T TRUST AND
THEY DON’T MUCH LIKE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
INSECURITY SENT OUT A SCARY
LOOKING BULLETIN TODAY WHICH
READ, INFORMATION SUGGESTS THAT
SOME IDEOLOGICALLY MOTIVATED
VIOLENT EXTREMISTS WITH THE
OBJECTION TO THE PRESIDENTIAL
TRANSITION HAS PERCEIVED
GRIEVANCES FIELD BY FALSE
NARRATIVES COULD CONTINUE TO
MOBILIZE TO INCITE OR COMMIT
VIOLENCE.
NOW, PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO THAT
LANGUAGE.
OBJECTIONS TO GOVERNMENTAL
AUTHORITY, OTHER PERCEIVED
GRIEVANCES, FALSE NARRATIVES,
COULD IMMOBILIZE -- COULD COMMIT
VIOLENCE.
SOUNDS OBSCENELY FAKE AND
HYPOTHETICAL, RIGHT?
IT THEN HEAR THE ACCOMPANYING
PRESS RELEASE, IT THEY ADMIT THE
TRUTH, THEY’VE GOT NOTHING.
DHS DOES NOT HAVE ANY
INFORMATION TO INDICATE ITS
SPECIFIC INCREDIBLE PLOTS.
ONCE AGAIN, IT’S OMINOUSLY
SLATING THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THEY REMAIN
CONCERNED DUE TO GRIEVANCES.
ETIOLOGICAL CAUSES, AND FALSE
NARRATIVES.
THIS IS IN THE FIRST TIMES
DEMOCRATS HAVE TRIED TO JUSTIFY
WHAT ULTIMATELY BE AN ATTEMPT TO
ROLL BACK YOUR CIVIL LIBERTIES.
REMEMBER BACK IN 2009, OBAMA’S
DHS SECRETARY WARNED ABOUT
RADICALIZED RETURNING VETERANS
AND THE RIGHT TO WING EXTREMISM
IN GENERAL.
SHE DEFINED IT AS MAINLY
ANTIGOVERNMENT.
IT MAY INCLUDE GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE DEDICATED
TO A SINGLE ISSUE, SUCH AS
OPPOSITION TO ABORTION OR
IMMIGRATION.
WHILE THE BIDEN BULLETIN DOES
MAKE A VAGUE REFERENCE TO BLM
AND NT FOLK WITHOUT NAMING THEM,
IT SPECIFICALLY LUMPS ANTILOCK
DOWN PROTESTERS INTO THE SAME
CATEGORY AS THE CAPITAL RIOTERS.
THE FBI APPARENTLY HAS PUT THEM
AT THE TOP OF THEIR MOST WANTED
LIST.
>> THE ENORMITY OF THIS
INVESTIGATION -- IS GOING TO
TAKE A LOT OF WORK AND EFFORT.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE SOLVED IN
THE COMING MONTHS.
IT WILL BE A LONG-TERM
INVESTIGATION.
>> THE BRUTALITY AMERICAN PEOPLE
WATCHED ON THE SIXTH WILL NOT BE
TOLERANTTOLERATED BY THE FBI.
WE WILL LEAVE NO STONE UNTURNED
IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: WE WANT ALL OF THE
CRIMINALS LOCKED UP, PERIOD.
BY THE WAY, THAT U.S. ATTORNEY
INTERESTING TO NOTE IS THE SAME
ONE WAS MORE THAN HAPPY TO DROP
CHARGES AGAINST DOZENS OF BLM
AND ANTIFA RIOTERS OVER THE
SUMMER.
JUST LIKE KEEPING THOUSANDS OF
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS IN
WASHINGTON UNTIL THE SPRING IS A
CHOREOGRAPHED SET UP A PIECE TO
JUSTIFY THE LEFTIST CAMPAIGN TO
INTIMIDATE, PUNISH, AND TO
SILENCE ULTIMATELY THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THIS EFFORT, IT’S NOT JUST A
MORAL, IT’S ILLEGAL.
IT’S UN-AMERICAN.
IN COURT, IN PRACTICE, IT SHOULD
BE DECLARED UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING A GRAVE
ERROR, HERE.
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
EVENTUALLY GET BACK INTO POWER,
AND WHEN THEY DO, THEY WILL
LEAVE NO STONE UNTURNED TO
INVESTIGATE ALL OF THIS, AND
THEN THE TABLES ARE GOING TO BE
TURNED ON THE AGENCIES AND TO
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ENDED UP
PROFILING AND TRACKING INNOCENT
AMERICANS.
UNTIL THEN, UNTIL THE COURTS
STEP IN, THEY ARE GOING TO TRY
TO SCARE YOU INTO SILENT
SUBMISSION.
WATCH THOSE EMAILS YOU ARE
SENDING.
IF YOU ARE A VET WHO ATTENDS AN
ANTI-LOCKDOWN PROTEST, IF YOU’VE
DONE SIDEWALK COUNSELING AT
ABORTION CENTERS, YOU FLY A
PLANETHINBLUE LINE MC FLAG, OR P
FACEBOOK AGAINST MAIL-IN
BALLOTS, YOU COULD BE SEEN
AS A POTENTIAL DOMESTIC
TERRORIST WHO COULD BE INCITED
TO VIOLENCE OR COMMIT VIOLENCE
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE SAW ON
JANUARY 6TH.
LET’S BE CLEAR, HE REPAIRED
THESE CHEAP EFFORTS ARE SO
TRANSPARENT, THE INTIMIDATION IS
NOT GOING TO WORK.
IT’S CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
DETER US FROM FIGHTING FOR WHAT
WE KNOW TO BE TRUE.
AS A DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE
MAKES CLEAR, OUR RIGHTS ARE
UNALIENABLE.
OUR FREEDOM COMES FROM GOD.
WE ARE NEVER REALLY GOING TO
GIVE IT UP FOR BIDEN OR HARRIS
OR THE MEDIA PALS.
CONSERVATIVES AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE REPEATEDLY
AND PROPERLY CONDEMNED ALL
VIOLENCE, NO MATTER WHO IS
COMMITTING IT.
IF THEY’VE URGED THE BIDEN FOLKS
TO WORK WITH US ON A BUNCH OF
ISSUES.
AOC AND HER RADICALS AS WELL TO
WORK WITH THE TO FIND COMMON
GROUND TO BREAK UP BIG TECH.
TO THIS A LOT WE CAN DO
TOGETHER.
IT THEY’VE DECIDED, THROW THAT
OUT THE WINDOW AND GO
SCORCHED-EARTH.
SPREAD LIES ABOUT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF INNOCENT AMERICANS.
IF THEY THINK THAT’S THE WAY TO
STOP POPULISM, BY ATTEMPTING TO
CRIMINALIZE IT, THEY ARE SORELY
MISTAKEN.
TODAY’S ANNOUNCEMENT CONFIRMED
TRUMP WAS RIGHT ALL ALONG.
WASHINGTON IS A SWAMP, IT’S RUN
BY SHADOWY FIGURES WHO WORK ON
AMASSING POWER FOR THEMSELVES,
REWARDING THEIR FRIENDS, AND
ROBBING THE WORKING CLASS
BLINDS.
THAT’S WHAT THEY MEANT WHEN THEY
SAID JOE BIDEN WOULD GET BACK
TO, REGULAR ORDER IF HE WAS
ELECTED.
EFFECTED THEY REGULAR ORDER.
THEY PROVED CRITICISM TO
CORRECT, THE MORE PUSHBACK THEY
WILL SEE.
THEY SHOULD’VE LEARNED THAT
LESSON IN 2016, THEY MAY HAVE TO
LEARN IT AGAIN IN 2024.
LET THERE BE NO CONFUSION HERE,
ARE POPULIST MOVEMENT IS LOYAL
TO THIS COUNTRY AND ITS
POLITICAL SYSTEM.
WE DON’T HAVE ANY DESIRE TO
ENGAGE IN VIOLENCE OR TO
UNDERMINE OUR SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE SILENCED.
AT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE STOOD UP
TO THE, WE STOOD UP TO THE
SOVIET UNION.
WE CAME SO FAR, WE ADDRESSED
PAST WRONGS.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO BACK DOWN TO